♪ ♪
>> I CAN TELL YOU ON COVID OR
CORONAVIRUS OR WHATEVER YOU WANT
TO CALL IT, PLENTY OF NAMES.
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS IS BEING
MADE.
WE STOPPED TESTING RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE VERY FEW CASES IF ANY.
>> WE’VE GOTTEN BETTER ON
TESTING SO THAT EXPLAINS A
LITTLE BIT WITHIN THE INCREASES
WE ARE SEEING INCREASES IN
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND THAT’S THE
REAL CONCERN.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS DISINCLINED
TO SHUT DOWN THE ECONOMY AS IS
THE VICE PRESIDENT.
>> I AGREE WITH MR. CODD LOW IN
THE WHITE HOUSE THAT WE DON’T
WANT TO SHUT DOWN AGAIN.
THE QUESTION ISN’T DO WE WANT TO
SHUT DOWN.
THE QUESTION IS CAN WE GET
CONTROL OF THE VIRUS.
>> Bret: THAT IS THE QUESTION.
HERE WE GO AGAIN.
FOCUSING ON COVID BECAUSE CASES
ARE INCREASING.
THERE IS MORE TESTING NATIONWIDE
BUT IF YOU LOOK THE NUMBERS HERE
IN THE U.S., 2.1 MILLION CASES.
116,000 DEATHS.
GLOBALLY YOU’RE AT 7.9, ALMOST
8 MILLION CASES.
434,000 DEATHS.
THE PRESIDENT MEANTIME LOOKING
AT THE DISPARITY IN COVERAGE AND
TWEETING "THE FAR LEFT FAKE NEWS
MEDIAL WHICH HAD NO COVID
PROBLEM WITH THE RIOTERS AND
LOOTERS DESTROYING DEMOCRAT RUN
CITIES IS TRYING TO COVID SHAME
US ON OUR BIG RALLIES.
WON’T WORK."
THEY ARE MOVING FORWARD WITH THE
RALLY IN TULSA, OKLAHOMA.
FOX NEWS SENIOR POLITICAL
ANALYST BRIT HUME.
MARA LIASSON, NATIONAL POLITICAL
CORRESPONDENT AT NATIONAL PUBLIC
RADIO.
CHRIS STIREWALT, POLITICS EDITOR
HERE AT FOX NEWS.
BRIT, WE ARE SEEING AN INCREASE
IN CASES.
WE ALWAYS POINT OUT THERE’S MORE
TESTING.
THE PRESIDENT POINTED THAT OUT
BUT THE EXPERTS ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT A RESURGENCE OF COVID.
>> IF SOME EXPERTS ARE CONCERNED
AND WE ARE SEEING INCREASES IN
SOME PLACES AND OTHERS THE
DECLINE CONTINUES, THE LARGER
QUESTION IS WAS TOUCHED ON BY
THE SOUND BITES, WHAT WE DO
ABOUT THE CASES THAT ARE TURNING
UP NOW, SOME AS A RESULT OF
CASES BEING DISCOVERED BY
TESTING.
SOME NEW INFECTIONS.
WHETHER WE ARE GOING TO GO BACK
TO LOCK DOWN IN SOME PLACES.
I DON’T THINK THERE’S ANY
APPETITE FOR POLITICALLY AND
UNLESS WE KNEW MORE ABOUT WHO
WAS BEING INFECTED AT HOW
SERIOUSLY AND WHETHER THEY ARE
GOING TO RECOVER, YOU CAN’T
REALLY MAKE A CASE FOR RESUMING
LOCKDOWNS IN PLACES WHERE
THEY’VE BEEN EASED.
I DON’T THINK IT MAKES ANY SENSE
AT ALL.
>> Bret: YEAH, I MEAN, TO YOUR
POINT, BRIT, THE UNIVERSITY OF
WASHINGTON AND THEY HAVE
ADJUSTED THEIR PREDICTIONS AND
EXPECTATIONS.
THEY ARE NOW PROJECTING 201,000
DEATHS BY OCTOBER.
THAT IS AN INCREASE OF 18%.
WE HAVE TRACKED THIS THROUGHOUT.
>> WELL, THE UNIVERSITY OF
WASHINGTON MODEL HAS BEEN OFF
TIME AND TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
IT’S SOMETHING OF A MODERN
MIRACLE THAT ALL OF US SEEM TO
BE PAYING SO MUCH ATTENTION TO
IT.
IT’S JUST A COMPUTER PROJECTION.
THESE HAVE BEEN WILDLY OFF.
WHAT THEY SAY NOW I DON’T THINK
COUNTS FOR ANYTHING.
>> Bret: MARA, WHAT ABOUT WHAT
THE PRESIDENT TALKS ABOUT, THE
DISPARITY IN COVERAGE NOT REALLY
A BIG PROBLEM WITH ALL THE
PROTESTS OF THE HILL -- THE
HEALTH EXPERTS WEIGHING IN.
>> HEALTH EXPERTS WILL SAY THAT
GOING OUT IN A BIG CROWD IS A
BAD IDEA WHETHER YOU ARE
PROTESTING OR YOU ARE GOING TO A
TRUMP RALLY.
BUT TRUMP IS GOING AHEAD WITH
THE RALLY.
HE CLEARLY HAS TAKEN SOME
PRECAUTIONS.
I THINK SOME PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
BE TESTED FOR TEMPERATURE.
THEY HAVE TO SIGN A WAIVER THAT
IF THEY GET SICK AFTER THEY GO
TO IT, THEY GET COVID, THEY ARE
NOT GOING TO SUE THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THIS IS A TRICKY PROBLEM.
WHAT BRIT SAID IS RIGHT.
IF YOU TEST A LOT OF PEOPLE, THE
NUMBERS ARE GOING TO GO UP.
THE PRESIDENT KIND OF DOESN’T
LIKE THAT.
ON THE OTHER HAND IF YOU TEST A
LOT OF PEOPLE, THEN YOU CAN TELL
PEOPLE WHO HAVE SYMPTOMS TO STAY
HOME AND THE OTHER ONES ARE
FINALLY GOING TO WORK AND HAVE A
BETTER HANDLE ON THE PROBLEM IN
GENERAL.
>> Bret: IS THE PRESIDENT
RIGHT TO POINT OUT THE DISPARITY
IN COVERAGE?
NBC HAD THESE TWEETS WITHIN AN
HOUR, ONE WAS A PROTEST WHERE IT
NOTED HOW MANY PEOPLE WERE THERE
AND THE OTHER WAS A TWEET ABOUT
THE DIRE WARNINGS ABOUT THE
TRUMP RALLY TO COME.
WITHIN ONE HOUR OF EACH OTHER.
WE ARE FOCUSED ON THE FACTS OF
WHERE THE CORONAVIRUS IS BUT
CLEARLY THERE’S A DIFFERENT
LEVEL IN COVERAGE.
>> HE CAN COMPLAIN ABOUT IT OR
HE CAN COMPLAIN ABOUT THE
WEATHER OR HE CAN COMPLAIN ABOUT
ANYTHING ELSE HE CAN’T CHANGE.
IT’S NOT LIKE NBC NEWS TOMORROW
IS GOING TO WAKE UP AND SAY
DONALD TRUMP IS ON THE BALL.
WE REALLY LIKE THIS GUY.
THE QUESTION IS AS WE LOOK AT
SATURDAY’S RALLY, CAN THEY
EXECUTED IT IN A WAY THAT’S
REASSURING AND COMPETENT?
COMPETENCY IS WHAT MATTERS.
THEY ARE GOING TO HAND OUT
MASKS.
WILL PEOPLE WEAR THE MASKS?
NO PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIAL WOULD
SAY JAMMING 18,000 PEOPLE AND IN
THE CLOSED SPACES A GOOD IDEA SO
THEY ARE ALREADY TAKING A
CHANCE.
CAN THEY EXECUTED IN A WAY THAT
LOOKS COMPETENT AND REASONABLE
AND RESPONSIBLE AS WOULD BE FIT
SOMEBODY SEEKING A SECOND TERM
IN OFFICE?
>> ONE THING THE PRESIDENT CAN
DO --
I’M SORRY, ONE THING I WAS GOING
TO SAY THE SMARTEST THING THE
PRESIDENT COULD DO IS MOVE HIS
RAILING OUTSIDE.
WHEN ALL THE PROTESTERS WERE
OUTSIDE IN HUGE NUMBERS AND A
LOT OF THE SINKABLE TO COMPLAIN
ABOUT THE CORONAVIRUS FELL
SILENT.
AS FAR AS FOR THE RACE, BIDEN IS
AHEAD.
HE’S BEEN AHEAD.
HE IS LIKELY TO REMAIN HEAD FOR
A WHILE.
DOESN’T MEAN THAT WHEN IT GETS
DOWN TO IT HE WILL WIN BUT IN MY
VIEW HE’S CERTAINLY AHEAD.
HOW BIG OF A MARGIN.
SOME POLLS SAY DOUBLE DIGITS.
WE WILL WAIT TO SEE IF THAT’S
DUPLICATED IN THE NEXT ROUND OF
POLLING.
>> Bret: WE HAVE SAID, WE ARE
STILL A LONG WAY OUT.
I WANT TO TURN TOPICS AND THIS
IS THE PRESIDENT ON
JOHN BOLTON’S UPCOMING BOOK.
MARA, I WANTED TO GET YOU TO
REACT TO WHAT HE.
>> HE WAS ADVISED VERY STRONGLY
NOT TO WRITE IT UNTIL IT’S
CLEARED AND HE COULDN’T WAIT AND
WE’LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS BUT I
THINK HE’S GOT -- I WOULD
IMAGINE HE HAS, LIKE WHEN YOU DO
CLASSIFIED, THAT TO ME IS A VERY
STRONG CRIMINAL PROBLEM.
HE KNOWS HE’S GOT CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
ANY CONVERSATION WITH ME IS
CLASSIFIED.
IT BECOMES EVEN WORSE IF HE LIES
ABOUT CONVERSATION.
WHICH I UNDERSTAND HE MIGHT HAVE
IN SOME CASES.
WE’LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> YOU KNOW --
>> Bret: OBVIOUSLY THE
WHITE HOUSE SEEMS LIKE IT’S
STILL GOING TO FIGHT IT.
>> THERE GOING TO FIGHT IT.
BOLTON’S LAWYER IS ADAMANT THERE
IS NO CLASSIFIED INFORMATION IN
IT, THAT HE FOLLOWED ALL THE
PROCEDURES, THAT HE PRESENTS OF
THE BOOKS FOR REVIEW AT THE
NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL
STARTING IN DECEMBER.
THERE’S GOING TO BE A BIG FIGHT
ABOUT IT BUT THEY ARE DETERMINED
TO GO FORWARD.
THERE’S BEEN A LOT OF BOOKS
WRITTEN BY FORMER TRUMP
OFFICIALS.
NONE OF THEM AS HIGH-RANKING AS
JOHN BOLTON AND NONE OF THEM AS
WE UNDERSTAND IT TO BE
POTENTIALLY NEGATIVE.
>> Bret: CHRIS, BUT HE DID NOT
TESTIFY DURING THE IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS OR ANYWHERE AROUND
THERE AND NOW IT IS BOOK TIME.
>> MAYBE BOLTON WILL GET REALLY
LUCKY AND THEY WILL TRY TO PUT
THEM IN JAIL AND HE CAN SELL A
MILLION MORE BOOKS.
WHEN YOU HAVE A TELL-ALL, WHEN
YOU HAVE ONE OF THESE KISS AND
TELL NUMBERS THAT COME OUT, THEY
WANT MAXIMUM CONTROVERSY.
I’VE NO IDEA WHAT’S IN BOLTON’S
BOOK BUT THE WHITE HOUSE AND